YOU JUST MIGHT SURPRISE ALL
EXPERTS IN NOVEMBER.
AND THAT THE "ANGLE."
JOINING A NUMBER REACTION FROM
WASHINGTON, D.C., IS THE
MAJORITY WHIP FOR THE HOUSE,
CONGRESSMAN STEVE SCALISE, A
REPUBLICAN WHO REPRESENTS, OF
COURSE, THE BRAVE STATE OF
LOUISIANA.
CONGRESSMAN SCALISE, IT'S GREAT
TO SEE YOU.
A PRETTY HARSH ASSESSMENT BY
YOURS TRULY ON THE BIG HULKING
OMNIBUS SPENDING BILL.
YOUR REACTION TO WHAT I SAY?
>> LAURA, FIRST, GREAT TO BE
BACK WITH YOU.
IF YOU LOOK AT A NUMBER OF THE
THINGS THAT ARE
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S PRIORITIES,
THEY ARE GOING TO BE IN THIS
BILL.
YOU START WITH THE FENCE.
THE BIGGEST PIECE OF THIS BILL
BY FAR, THE FUNDING OF OUR
NATION'S DEFENSE, WHICH ACTUALLY
RESTORES THE ABILITY FOR OUR
COUNTRY TO PROVIDE FOR OUR MEN
AND WOMEN IN UNIFORM AND RESTORE
A LOT OF THE DAMAGE THAT
BARACK OBAMA DID.
WE WORK CLOSELY WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
SECRETARY MATTIS.
WE SAW TWO MORE PLANES FALL OUT
OF THE SKY LAST NIGHT, WE
FINALLY RESTORED AIR SUPERIORITY
IN THIS FIELD.
GIVEN OUR TROOPS A PAY RAISE.
THERE ARE TREMENDOUS
PRESIDENT TRUMP REPUBLICAN
PRIORITIES IN THIS BILL.
>> Laura: I'VE GOT TO GET IN
ON THIS SEQUESTER CAP.
I KNOW THIS WAS CONSIDERED A
VERY HIGH MAKE HARSH MEASURE.
WHEN THE SEQUESTER CAPS WERE IN,
HE DIDN'T DECREASE SPENDING,
THEY DECREASED THE RATE OF
INCREASE IN SPENDING, CRAZY
WASHINGTON SPEAK.
THERE WERE CUTBACKS, BUT THE
CUTBACKS ARE ACROSS-THE-BOARD.
IN THE BUDGET DEFICIT UNDER
OBAMA, AND FOR A FEW YEARS, DID
BEGIN TO GO DOWN.
NOW REPUBLICANS ARE IN CHARGE,
LIKE, WELL, THE MILITARY NEEDS
ANOTHER 300 MILLION AND THIS
PROJECT NEEDS A COUPLE
$20 BILLION HERE AND $30 BILLION
HERE, AND WE TURN AROUND,
AND THE REPUBLICANS ARE THE
PARTY OF BIG SPENDING,
CONGRESSMAN.
SO HOW DO WE, AS CONSERVATIVES,
HOLD UP THAT MANTLE OF FISCAL
RESPONSIBILITY IF, INDEED, WE'RE
BLOWING THE BUDGET AGAIN?
BECAUSE WE ARE GOING TO MORE
MONEY ON THE MILITARY?
>> ONE OF OUR BASIC FUNCTIONS AS
A GOVERNMENT IS TO PROVIDE FOR
OUR NATIONAL DEFENSE.
WE SHOULDN'T HIT FISCAL
DISCIPLINE AGAINST PROVIDING FOR
OUR DEFENSE.
>> Laura: AT $700 MILLION?
THAT'S A LOT OF DOUGH.
>> IT'S A LOT, BUT, AGAIN, WHEN
YOU TALK ABOUT RESTORING BECAUSE
BARACK OBAMA MADE, THIS IS NOT
BEING DONE ON THE BACKS OF -- IF
YOU LOOK AT WHAT IS DRIVING OUR
DEBT, WE KNOW WHAT IS DRIVING
OUR DEBT, WE HAVE ADDRESSED
THAT, LOOK AT SOME OF THE
PROBLEMS IN TERMS OF WHAT THE
CBO SCORES ESSAY, THEY SAY OUR
TAX CUT BILL IS WHAT BLUE      B
TAX CUT BILL IS WHAT BLUE      E
TAX CUT BILL IS WHAT BLUE      W
TAX CUT BILL IS WHAT BLUE      A
TAX CUT BILL IS WHAT BLUE      H
TAX CUT BILL IS WHAT BLUE      L
TAX CUT BILL IS WHAT BLUE      E
IN OUR DEFICIT.
SEEING NOT ONLY COMPANIES GIVING
THOSE, BUT SEEING PEOPLE GETTING
OUT OF UNEMPLOYMENT.
>> Laura: I COULDN'T AGREE
WITH YOU MORE.
YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
NO DOUBT ABOUT THAT.
BUT THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY,
CONGRESSMAN, TO DEFUND SANCTUARY
CITIES AND TO GET THE REAL MONEY
FOR THE WALL THAT THE PRESIDENT
CAMPAIGNED ON.
AND HE WILL MAKE THE ELECTION ON
THAT.
DEFUND PLANNED PARENTHOOD, YOU
I HAVE A BILLION DOLLARS TO
PLANNED PARENTHOOD.
REPUBLICANS ARE IN CHARGE AND
THEY PUNCH IT.
THAT IS MIND-BOGGLING.
>> I SHARE YOUR FRUSTRATION
THERE.
BUT IF YOU LOOK AT THIS BILL,
PRESIDENT TRUMP WILL HAVE THE
ABILITY TO DEFUND SANCTUARY
CITIES IN THIS BILL, AND I
SUPPORT THE PRESIDENT AND SAYING
WE NOT ONLY GOING TO GO AFTER
SANCTUARY CITIES BUT SANCTUARY
STATES.
THERE IS A BIG FIGHT GOING ON,
AND I'M GLAD PRESIDENT TRUMP
SAID, WE WILL CONFRONT THIS
PARTY HAS THAT ABILITY.
FUNDING OF THE WALL, THAT IS
SOMETHING WE ARE NEGOTIATING IN
THE FINAL STAGES RIGHT NOW THAT
HASN'T BEEN COMPLETELY RELEASED
YET, BUT I THINK WE'LL HAVE THE
ABILITY FOR THE PRESIDENT TO
START BUILDING THE WALL WITH
THIS BILL.
WE'VE GOT WINS FOR THE
PRESIDENT, BUT YOU WANT TO TALK
ABOUT WHAT'S DRIVING OUR DEBT,
NUMBER ONE, I DON'T THINK TAX
CUTS ARE GOING TO BLOW A
TRILLION DOLLAR HOLE IN THERE.
ECONOMIC GROWTH IS HAPPENING,
AND WE ARE GOING TO ULTIMATELY
HAVE LESS THAN A TRILLION DOLLAR
DEFICIT.
SAVING MEDICARE FROM BANKRUPTCY
BANKRUPTCY --
>> Laura: I GOT THAT, BUT
CONGRESSMAN, WE'VE GOT TO BE
HONEST WITH THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
YOU KNOW I ADORE YOU, BUT WE
HAVE TO BE HONEST WITH THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
PLANNED PARENTHOOD WILL BE FULLY
FUNDED IN THIS BILL, CORRECT?
>> NOT FULLY FUNDED.
LOOK, THEY'VE BEEN GETTING
FUNDED FOR A LONG TIME.
WERE TRYING TO ROLL THAT BACK.
OUR HEALTH CARE BILL, WHICH
PASSED BY ONE VOTE, WOULD HAVE
FULLY DEFUNDED PLANNED
PARENTHOOD.
WE'VE GOT TO CONTINUE THAT
FIGHT.
I'M NOT DUMB OF THAT FIGHT.
I HAVE WORKED CLOSELY WITH ALL
THE PRO-LIFE GROUPS.
WE ARE GOING TO BE ROLLING BACK
SOME OF THE MONEY THAT THEY ARE
GETTING.
WE'VE GOT TO CONTINUE TO BATTLE
TO GET THAT DONE.
>> Laura: THE SANCTUARY
CITIES, IT HAS TO BE DEFUNDED.
>> THE PRESIDENT WILL PURSUE
THAT, THE BIG GATEWAY PROJECT
YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT, THE
BOONDOGGLE.
HOPEFULLY WE WILL BE ABLE TO
DEFUND THAT IN THIS BILL, TAKE A
LOOK WHEN THE FINAL INK IS DRY,
A LOT OF THESE PROJECTS ARE
TALKING ABOUT, I AGREE
COMPLETELY ON.
ONCE THIS BILL IS DONE, I THINK
YOU WILL HAVE THAT ABILITY WHILE
RESTORING OUR NATION'S DEFENSE
TO THE SUPERIORITY IT DESERVES
AND RESTORING A LOT OF THE CUTS
BARACK OBAMA MADE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP WANTS THIS BILL.
>> Laura: LET'S GO TO SPECIAL
COUNSEL.
BOTH YOU, NOW, YOU HAVE JOINED
KEVIN McCARTHY, OTHER LEADERS
IN THE HOUSE AND THE SENATE, ALL
BELIEVING IT IS TIME FOR A
SECOND SPECIAL COUNSEL TO
EXAMINE THE RUSSIAN PROBE AND
THE HILLARY EMAIL PROBE GIVEN
WHAT WE HAVE LEARNED ABOUT THE
FBI.
WHY A SECOND SPECIAL COUNSEL
WITH ENDLESS BUDGET AND ALMOST
NO ACCOUNTABILITY?
HOW IS THAT THE RIGHT ANSWER?
>> LAURA, RIGHT NOW I THINK WE
DON'T HAVE THE ACCOUNTABILITY WE
DESERVE.
WE HAVE SEEN SERIOUS QUESTIONS
RAISED FROM THE HOUSE'S
INVESTIGATION INTO WHAT IS GOING
ON WITH THE SPECIAL COUNSEL.
IT'S NOT JUST THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL.
HE GOES FAR BEYOND THAT.
YOU SEE THE ABUSES, POTENTIALLY,
OF THE FISA PROCESS, A VERY
IMPORTANT PROCESS.
IF FBI AGENTS WERE ABUSING THAT,
AND I THINK MOSTLY THIS IS
COMING FROM SOME OF THE TOP
LEVEL FBI AGENTS GOING BACK TO
THE OBAMA REGIME.
THE FBI DOES GREAT WORK AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL.
FRANKLY, AT SOME OF THEIR
CREDIBILITY HAS BEEN CALLED INTO
QUESTION.
REPORTS THAT HAVE COME OUT.
I THINK A SECOND SPECIAL COUNSEL
TO LOOK INTO SOME OF THESE
ABUSES THAT WE HAVE SEEN, AND
THE SERIOUS QUESTIONS THAT ARE
RAISED, I THINK IT IS WELL IN
ORDER TO RESTORE THE CONFIDENCE
IN THE FBI THAT IS DESPERATELY
NEEDED.
>> Laura: ARE YOU SURPRISED,
CONGRESSMAN SCALISE, THAT AFTER
WE LEARNED THAT THE FBI BLEW TWO
CHANCES TO INTERVENE AGAINST
NIKOLAS CRUZ, BOTH ON THAT
YOUTUBE VIDEO POSTING AND IN THE
TIP LINE WHEN HE BASICALLY TOLD
HE WAS GOING TO FILL UP THE
SCHOOL, THAT WE NEVER -- AS FAR
AS I COULD TELL, WE NEVER HAVE
SEEN CHRISTOPHER WRAY, THE FBI
DIRECTOR, ADDRESS HOW THIS
HAPPENED, HOW WE ARE GOING TO
PREVENT THIS FROM HAPPENING
AGAIN.
DOES THAT CONCERN YOU IN THE
WAKE OF THE PARKLAND SHOOTING?
>> IT ACTUALLY DOES LAURA.
I KNOW YOU AND I HAVE TALKED
ABOUT THIS BEFORE.
ONE OF THE PASSIONS I HAVE IS TO
FIND OUT EXACTLY WHO HAD HIS
FILE.
CRUZ SAID, I'M GOING TO BE A
SCHOOL SHOOTER.
>> Laura: WHERE IS WRAY?
WHY HASN'T HE COME OUT?
>> I WANT TO KNOW WHO HANDLED
THAT FILING MADE THE DECISION TO
NOT PURSUE HIM, AND ULTIMATELY
THAT LED TO HIM GOING OUT AND
MASSACRING 17 PEOPLE.
IT SHOULD HAVE NEVER HAPPENED.
SAW SOME PROBLEMS WITH LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT TOO THAT ANGERED ME.
IN TERMS OF OVERSIGHT, WE HAVE
OVERSIGHT OVER THE FBI, AND I
THINK WE DESERVE AND THE PUBLIC
DESERVES TO KNOW JUST BY THE FBI
DROPPED THE BALL IN THIS